All right guys, so this is an example for the buys.
Of course, this is hindsight,
it's not gonna always work.
And this is, the auto-flow trading strategy
is not my favorite one, but you can back test it
and you know, get used to it, if that makes sense, all right?
So what we have here is that we create a higher high,
a higher low, and then another higher high.
So basically, we broke the structure
and now this is a continuation of a trend, okay?
And what do we have here?
Imbalance plus auto-block, but what happens here?
Price does not hit the auto-block,
but it hits the imbalance.
So this is what I say that sometimes I'm gonna take entries
of the imbalance, sometimes of the auto-block.
I always take my entry from the imbalance,
if the imbalance is very short like this, okay?
So I would take my entry right around here
and I put my stop plus here
and I go for this level right around here.
This would have been a 3.73.
Now we can see we created another higher high,
which is this, okay?
And then we got this imbalance plus the auto-block, okay?
So now what happens here is that you can see
we have marked the auto-block,
but what it did, it just maybe stopped you out.
But if you wanna be on the safe side,
what you can do is put your stop below this low.
Okay, because sometimes, and I'm saying sometimes,
I'm looking at this at the five minute timeframe, right?
But on the one minute timeframe,
there could be another imbalance and auto-block
around in this week, okay?
This whole week is a price action as well.
So maybe on the 30 second timeframe
or 15 second timeframe, there was an imbalance
plus auto-block right around here.
So make sure you put your stop plus here
just to be on the safe side.
And as you can see, we go up targeting this high
and then we broke the structure once again,
which is right here.
And then you can see we got the extreme
fair value gap at this level.
There's no imbalance here, it's all filled, all filled.
And we got this auto-block here.
And you can see we got a perfect entry around this level.
We would have entered here and boom,
targeting the high.
That was a 5.72 risk to reward trade guys.
Very, very simple guys.
And yeah, this is how we trade.
And let me give you another example.
We broke the structure again.
So there is the extreme fair value gap around this level.
So you could have entered from the fair value gap
or you could have your entry around this auto-block,
but then you would have missed the entry
by one people.
But just to just, I want to tell you guys this one thing,
you should always put your entry a little
above your actual entry point to deal
with the spreads of the broker, right?
Because sometimes, due to the spreads,
you will not get your entry if your entry
is exactly at the auto-block, okay?
So make sure you always have your entry a little shy
above the actual entry point.
And then you can see price went all the way up.
So we are done with the auto-flow trading strategy,
my least favorite trading strategy,
but it can be your most favorite trading strategy, okay?
So as I said before, in the course,
you must choose one strategy and work on it.
You should not try out a lot of other strategies.
So I'll see you guys in my next trading strategy video.